Çeviri: Gülnar Khalilova Akdish
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Ben bir kadın girişimciyim.
Son 20 yıldır pazarlama alanında
farklı şirketler kurdum ve sattım.
Bugün burada hem bir kadın
hem bir girişimci olarak
size kadın ve erkekler olarak
üstlendiğimiz rollerden
biraz bahsedeceğim.
İzmir'liyim.
Söylediği sözün anlam ifade ettiği
bir ailede büyüdüm.
Benden 5 yaş küçük bir erkek kardeşim var.
Babam girişimci.
Hesapsız alınan risklerin
ne anlama geldiğini
14 yaşımda babam iflas edince öğrendim.
O zaman iki şeye karar verdim.
Bir, kendi ayaklarım üzerinde
durmam gerekiyordu.
İki, iyi bir eğitim almam gerekiyordu.
Liseyi İzmir'de okudum,
üniversite için İstanbul'a geldim.
Okulu bitirdikten sonra her genç kız gibi
bir uluslararası şirkette
çalışmaya başladım-
-çünkü kariyerim öyleydi-
ardından evlendim,
evlendiğimde bir kız çocuğum oldu
ve işi bıraktım çünkü annelik benim
zaten kariyerimdeki en önemli roldü.
Fakat yine hesaplamadığım bir şey oldu,
hesaplayamamıştım.
Bir, evde oturmak çok sıkıcıydı.
İki, boşanmıştım.
İşte, iş kurmaya karar verdiğim
tam da bu zamana rastlar.
Uzun süre düşündüğüm ve pek çok kere
pek çok kişiye danıştığım
bir süreç geçirdim.
Burada genel olarak bana söylenen şey,
bir kadın olduğum,
neden iş kurmak istediğim,
küçücük bir çocuğumun olduğu
ve tanımadığım insanlarla
iş yapmamam gerektiğiydi.
Aslında bugün dönüp baktığmda,
bunun sadece bana ait bir problem
olmadığını görüyorum.
İşte o yüzden sizinle Abbie Conant'ın
hikayesini paylaşmak istiyorum.
Abbie Conant trombon çalan bir müzisyen.
Trombon çalıyor ve Turin operasında.
1980 yazına geldiğinde bir işe
başvurmak istiyor
ve Münih Filarmoni
orkestrasına başvuruyor.
Kabul mektubu geliyor kendisine.
Mektup geldiğinde üstünde şöyle
bir ifade var:
"Herr" Abbie Conant - Bay Abbie Conant
geliyor.
Ama bu küçük ayrıntıya
pek de takılmıyor kendisi.
Seçmeler için Münih'e gidiyor.
O dönemde Münih Filarmoni Orkestrasının
binası tamirde olduğu için
Münih operasında seçmeler yapılıyor,
Fakat orkestrada çalışanların
birinin de yakını
seçmelere katıldığı için seçimler
perde arkasında yapılıyor.
O zamana kadar Avrupa'da perde arkasında
seçim yapmak pek de olağan bir şey değil.
33 kişi seçimlere giriyor.
Abbie Conant'ın sıra numarası 16.
Sıra kendine geldiğinde,
sahneye çıkıyor ve trombonunu
çalmaya başlıyor.
François Davit'in konçertosunu çalıyor.
Ancak çalarken 1 notayı kaçırıyor.
Çok üzgün bir biçimde sahnenin
arkasına doğru gidiyor,
eşyalarını toplamaya başlıyor.
"Herhalde artık beni seçmeyecekler"
diye düşünürlerken,
sahnenin önünde seçim yapanlar
hiç de öyle düşünmüyorlar.
Konçertoyu duydukları itibaren
oldukça etkilenmişlerdir
ve diğerlerini duymaya gerek görmeden
Abbie'nin kazandığını açıklarlar ve
"Bay Abbie Conant" sahneye gelir,
Perde açılır...Uzun bir sessizlik...
"Aman Tanrım, bu bir kadınmış"
O zamana kadar Münih
Filarmoni Orkestrasında
kadınlar iki tane çalgı çalarlar.
Bir tanesi keman, diğeri de obuadır.
Bunlar kadınların ince,
zarif parmakları için çok uygundur.
Oysa ki trombon. Tam bir erkek çalgısıdır.
Hatta o kadar ki aynı zamanda
marşları çalarlar.
Ayrıca trombon çalmak için
çok güçlü nefese ihtiyaç duyulur.
Bir kadın nasıl olur da
böyle bir şey çalar.
Neyse kabul edilir.
Ancak biraz zaman geçtikten sonra,
yanlarına çağırır maestro ve der ki:
"Bundan sonra artık
baş tromboncu değilsin."
"Neden?"
"Çünkü fiziksel olarak senin
bu kadar yetkinliğin yok!"
Abbie çok sinirlenir ve
mahkemeye başvurur.
Mahkeme ondan bir sağlık raporu ister,
Kendisi sağlık raporu almak için
hastaneye gider.
Hemşire muayeneyi bitirdikten sonra
ona şu soruyu sorar:
"Siz atlet misiniz?
Ne kadar güçlü ciğerleriniz var"
Abbie raporu alır ve tekrar döner.
Fakat geri döndüğünde bu sefer de
orkestrada maaş farklılıkları
olduğunu görür.
Sadece kadın olduğu için
erkeklerden daha az ücret almaktadır.
Tekrar mahkemeye gider
ve mahkeme tam 8 yıl sürer.
Sonunda kendi kazanır ve Abbie Conant
artık Münih Filarmoni Orkestrası'nda
trombon çalmaya devam eder.
Fakat o günden sonra ne olur,
biliyor musunuz?!
Orkestralarda seçimler perde arkasında
yapılmaya başlar ve
perde sayesinde gerçek yetenekler
keşfedilmeye başlar.
O günden sonra Amerika'da
Filarmoni Orkestraları'nda,
%5 olan kadın oranı %55lere çıkar.
Sadece kadınlar için değil,
Asyalılar için de, Afrikalılar için de ,
Güney Amerikalılar içerisinde de
müzisyenlerin oranı artar.
Müzik dünyasının keşfettiği şey şuydu:
Yargılarınız kadın ve erkek
rollerini belirlememeli,
gözünüze perde çekmemeli.
Çünkü kadınların ve erkeklerin
yapabildiklerini düşünmek,
gerçek yetenekleri
değerlendirmemizi engeller.
Aynı iş dünyasında olduğu gibi .
Prof. Dr. Yıldız Ecevit şöyle diyor,
girişimcilikle ilgili yaptığı araştırmada.
Kadınların %39'u iş kurmak istediklerinde,
şöyle bir yanıt alıyorlar:
"Sen yapamazsın."
%37'sine, "Ne gerek var, evde otur,
zaten beceremezsin" denerek küçümseniyor.
%10'una önce en yakınları "hayır" diyor.
Aslında girişimciliğe baktığınız zaman
başka sorunları da var kadınların.
Finansa ulaşmakta, network kurmakta.
Ve bütün bu sorunlar içerisinde
kadın kendini yalnız hissediyor.
Dünyada nüfusun yarısını
kadınlar oluşturuyor,
ancak fırsatlara erkekler kadar
rahat ulaşamıyorlar.
Nereden mi biliyorum bunları?
Sizinle bazı rakamları
paylaşmak istiyorum.
Dünyada 22 tane kadın devlet başkanı var.
Parlamentoda temsil olunanı %21.
Eğer dünyada kadınlar ve erkeklerin
fırsatları eşit olsaydı, dünya ekonomisi
85 milyar dolar daha zengin olacaktı.
Peki Türkiyede durum nasıl?
Ora ile de ilgili
bazı rakamlar paylaşayım.
Türkiye'de kadınların
iş gücüne katılım oranı %33.
OECD ortalaması %58.
Türkiye'de sadece
sekiz milyon yüz bin kadın çalışıyor,
4 milyon yüz bini kayıt dışı.
Yani kayıt dışında çalışan kadınların
hepsini bir ile toplasak,
inanın, İzmir ili kadar etmiyor.
Türkiye'de girişimci kadın sayısı 105 bin,
toplam girişimcilerin %8'i.
Ve Dünya ekonomik raporu diyor ki,
kadın ve erkeklerin fırsatlara
eşit olabilmesi için
118 yıl daha geçmesi gerekiyor .
Yani benim torunumun çocuğu
ancak görebilecek.
Yargılar önemli.
Size neyi nasıl yapamadığınızı
söyleyecekler.
Ve bunu daha kız çocuğuyken
size söylemeye başlayacaklar.
Aynı bu videoda olduğu gibi.
(Video) Kızları sınırlandırıyor muyuz?
Onlara sorduk.
Kız olduğun için sana bazı şeyleri
yapmaman gerektiği söylendi mi?
Evet.
Her zaman, her zaman, sürekli.
İnsanlar kızları hep mutlu ve neşeli
olması gerektiğini düşünüyor.
Bilirsin işte.
Olması gereken gibi ol,
zorlu bir şeyler yapmaya kalkma.
Birini gerçekten
kurtaramayacağımı söylediler.
Örneğin hikayelerde kızları
hep erkekler kurtarır.
Kızların %72'si toplumun onları
sınırladığını hissediyor
Orkid bunu değiştirmek istiyor.
Şuradaki kutulardan birini alıp buraya
getirmenizi istiyorum.
Kutu sınırlarını temsil ediyor.
(Kızlar mükemmel olmalı)
Her bir kutuya söylediğiniz
şeylerden birini yazın lütfen.
(Kuvvetsiz)
(Kızlar güçlü değil.)
(Spor spikeri olamazlar)
(Cesaret edemez)
Ergenlik döneminde kızların öz güveni
düşüştedir.
Sınırlamaları kabul etme eğilimi
gösterirler.
Geri adım atmaya ve yeni şeyler
denememeye başladım.
ve...bunlar beni kısıtladı.
Trompeti, basketbolu bıraktım,
güreş sporunu bıraktım.
Ben...kendi kendime
iyi değilsen bırak gitsin dedim.
Bıraktın mı peki?
Bir hafta için.
Sonra ne oldu?
Onlara daha iyisini yapmak için
çok çalışarak aksini ispatladım.
Nasıl davranacağımı başka insanların
isteklerine göre karar veriyordum.
Sonra fark ettim ki bu korkunç birşey
Öyleyse "Yeter artık!" dedim.
"O kutuyla ne yapmak istiyorsun?"
"Kutuyu gerçekten kırmak
veya patlatmak istiyorum."
"Vurmak."
"Haydi!"
"Bir dakika ciddi misin sen?"
"Bence yapmayı sevdiğin neyse
buna devam etmeli ve
istediğin her şeyi yapmalısın.
İçindeki her korkuyu zapt edebilir
ve hayallerini yaşayabilirsin,
ve istediğin her şeyi yapabilirsin.
"Durdurulmaz" kelimesini
bu yüzden seviyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Ve durdurulamaz bir kadın daha var,
Helen Clark.
Kendisi Yeni Zelanda'nın
tam 9 yıl başbakanlığını yapıyor.
Başbakanlığının son günlerinde bir
okula çağırılıyor
ve bir konuşma yapması isteniyor.
Konuşmayı yaptıktan sonra bir grup
kız çocuğu yanına yaklaşıyor.
Çok endişeliler.
Endişeli gözlerle ona soruyorlar:
"Size bir soru sorabilir miyiz?"
"Buyurun" diyor, Helen Clark.
"Biz çok korkuyoruz, çok endişeliyiz.
Doğduğumuzdan beri
ülkeyi siz yönetiyorsunuz.
Acaba ülkemizi bir erkek yönetebilir mi?
Yargılarımız. Gözümüzün önündeki perdeler.
Ama biliyor musunuz,
iyi haberim var bir size.
Değişim başladı.
Artık yeni dünyada,
dijitalleşmiş bu dünyada,
kadınlar ve erkekler artık fırsatlara
her zamankinden daha yakınlar.
Artık kocaman, zamanı ve
yeri olmayan dünyada yaşıyoruz.
Bilgi elimizin altında.
Dolayısıyla değiştirmek ve
dönüştürmek için
artık çok fazla zamanımız var
ve bu geçirdiğimiz kötü günlerde
biliyor musunuz, kadının
nasıl bir becerisi var.
Transformasyon. Değiştirme.
Kötüyü iyileştirme gücü var.
Bakın, uzun zamandır dünya ülkelerinde,
kadınlar başbakanlık ediyor.
IMF'in, FED'in başkanı kadın.
Almanya, İngiltere ve belki de
Amerika'nın Başkanı kadın olacak.
Bu tesadüf değil.
Kadınların bu liderlik becerileri ile
dünyayı daha güzelleştirmek için
daha fazla açığa çıkması gerekiyor.
Bugün burada kadınlar kadar
erkekler de var.
HE FOR SHE'ler- onların desteklediği
kadınlarla
ve kendine güvenen kadınlarla
ve en büyük destekçimiz olan,
Cumhuriyetimizin kurucusu Ata'mızın
bize verdiği bu haklarla
ben, önümüzün her zamankinden
daha açık olacağına inanıyorum.
Birlikte, hep beraber.
En güzel geleceği el ele,
birlikte yaratabiliriz.
Cumhuriyet Bayramınız kutlu olsun!
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)